good evening ladies and gentlemen and
welcome to the rayman legends come foot
tournament as you can see many of your
favorite youtubers are partaking in an
epic battle for dominance so if their
videos are posted there will be an
annotation right here on their lovely
faces to click to see their first round
battle if not then you keep an eye on
their channel to see it anyway so our
battle is up next let's get to it
my name is mark byron i big blue guy oh
my god yeah
splits beaten down line aah okay don't
do it let's put this written here I was
so quiet I'm shot
focus smart [ __ ] I am focused aah
I'm on the brain here yes sir yes yo
vegan this is still the Xbox thing oh
yeah Oh on the back from back
now I'm using this whole time you
haven't I have an outside no not even
what do you mean even outside I mean
like I don't know where we go
I try to get it up so we can get some
hair Oh that'll keep you around here
stop your shenanigans people we should
be hanging up huh good eye but the ball
I mean yes now get back in the door here
duck in the fuel make free from the
other free why you yelling at me won't
make me any better I'm sorry big uns I'm
sorry hahaha
you're doing good huh
can it wait get away get away get all
right oh yeah ha ha again Steven stone
up ha ha ha
we can do this come on I'm not sure I
again are you ready Joe you really want
office are you ready
wait wait wait they talked about the
same character by the way where's what
they just Flopsy why have you no idea
because it's important it's the she
Namecheap did out of here man she she
she shy
whoa aha give me a heart attack man hey
wait I'm just like backup wow wow
I'm diggin don't make a deal that wasn't
my fault
yes go oh you're high bunch of me keep
unto me keep it up don't keep it up keep
it down keep it why are you in my goal
is that really helping your team outs
huh Ricky
yeah yeah Taiyo shows just iPad Oh
Jackson oh I'm not trying yes you are No
oh you're right I'm not [ __ ] it's a
fight here the goalie oh by the way I
was a goalie close go legal I love you
man
ah fifteen forever but peel the muscles
tense I got some Zagat's I felt them but
he was power yeah boy
yeah
ah thank you Oh Govinda next good